[Music]
everything starts the day your mum's egg
meets your dad's sperm
four weeks later your little brain
begins to form
epidemiologist david barker says that
whilst developing inside our mother
we are receiving postcards from the
outside world
these postcards tell us if this world is
dangerous or
safe if food is plentiful or scarce
knowing nothing else we learn from those
messages
let's watch what we experience and learn
inside the womb from the fetus
perspective
month 1
[Music]
only 24 hours alive every bit of genetic
information
is already present in a single cell from
our hair colour to our talent as a
future pianist
then we divide ourselves again and again
after around a week we travel from the
ovaries to the uterus
where we then undergo the great divide
splitting into two
half of which will become us while the
other half forms the placenta
which brings us food and oxygen and
carries away
waste by week four we have developed
into
a small being that is growing at a rate
of 1 million
cells per second our spinal cord
heart and brain are now clearly visible
even if we are just the size of a poppy
seed
month two at about week four to five
our heart starts to beat and we are now
ten thousand times bigger than we were
at conception
this is a crucial point in our
neurological development
as our brain grows at a rate of around a
hundred thousand cells
each minute if our mother consumes
alcohol and drugs
or experiences extreme stress or trauma
our tiny brain can get damaged this can
lead to maths problems at school
or even schizophrenia some 40 years
later
if our mom stays healthy and can relax
our brain can develop to its full
potential we are now the size of a
raspberry
month 3 at the beginning of month 3 we
start to react to stimuli
our sense of smell is developing and
exposure to toxins can make us
cringe our brain is continuing to grow
very fast our ears start forming and we
can soon hear
our mum's heartbeat and voice speak
still small enough we have plenty of
space to move inside the belly
our mother's womb becomes our sensory
playground
we learn to move our arms stretch our
fingers
smile or suck our thumb seventy-five
percent of us are now showing a
preference to use the right hand
we are now around the size of a lemon
month 4 our head makes up about half our
total size
we learn to kick pee and how to swallow
our taste buds are developing if our
mother eats a wide variety of things
we learn to appreciate different tastes
and become less fussy eaters later in
life
if we receive inadequate or poor
nutrients we adapt our physiology
to sustain our development this process
is also called
fetal programming some researchers have
found that this can result in health
problems
such as obesity heart conditions and
diabetes later in life
we are now around the size of a big
tomato
month five while earlier our mom's voice
sounded muffled
now it is starting to become clear we
are also experiencing a big
growth spurt and we start the
development of our teeth and our first
real hair
fingernails eyebrows and eyelashes
we are becoming more active each day and
enjoying flexing our tiny muscles
as we wriggle kick and turn our mother
will start to feel us moving
if she responds we learn that for every
action there is a reaction
we are now around the size of a dragon
fruit
[Music]
during this sixth month a major mark of
brain development
occurs our brain's cerebral cortex
splits into two hemispheres but it's
also an exciting month for our eyes
which open for the first time even
though we see only blurs
we start to respond to light some say
it's good if our mum now takes us into
the sun
we are now starting to make simple
facial expressions
such as forming a grin we probably learn
to communicate
for the time when we are born when we
want to show our feelings
we are now around the size of a small
cauliflower
month 7 we begin to develop
regular intervals for sleeping and being
awake
the hair on our head is now clearly
visible and our milk
teeth have formed under our gums when we
hear our mum speak
we may respond with an increased
heartbeat and movement
some researchers claim that we now begin
to learn language
from hearing the voices from outside
because once born
we seem to show a preference for our
dads and mom's native language
if we were to be born now we would have
a 90
chance of survival and arrive the size
of a pineapple
month eight we are now behaving like a
newborn
our brain is functional and our nervous
system ready
our lungs are almost fully formed and we
are practicing breathing by inhaling
amniotic fluid we now spend almost
all of our time asleep maybe dreaming
about our near future
in preparation for birth most of us will
have now turned upside down
to get through that tiny hole at the end
of the tunnel
our bones and skull are still extremely
flexible
only the immune system is still in its
infancy
it will take many months after birth
until our internal bodyguards can fully
protect our health
we are now around the size of a melon
[Music]
month nine in the last month we keep
practicing our motor skills and
cakes when our mum laughs eat sweets or
drinks in iced tea
we might respond by bouncing up and down
if we could already understand
research papers we would now hope that
our mum can bring us to the world
through natural birth
which protects us through a stronger
immune system for life
the puzzle of what is nurture and what
is nature is now well underway
and already shows a first image of our
character
the most important missing piece will be
added in our early childhood
at the end of the nine months we are
around the size of a jackfruit
[Music]
after many hours of hard labor we will
be welcomed into this world
some will then be instantly taken away
for various checkup procedures and
bathing
but if we are lucky we will first spend
some time with our mum
if placed on her belly we will
instinctively crawl to her breast
and then show our sucking skills this
makes us happy
full and feel safe the foundation for
all
future learning
[Music]
millions of students from all around the
globe have watched our sprouts videos
for better learning
thousands of teachers play them in their
classrooms to start
projects volunteers on youtube have
translated them to over 25 languages
our mission is to promote learning by
doing in classrooms around the world
if you are a great explainer and a
passionate teacher
and you want to help us develop
outstanding content
contact us to support our channel with a
donation
visit patreon.com sprouts
you